[Música]
bienvenidos a ello soy de france 24 a
mediados de julio la fiscalía de
estadounidense anunció la investigación
contra un complot para secuestrar y
sacar del país a la periodista y
activista iraní estadounidense macy
alineyad alineyad reside en eeuu desde
2014 y ha dedicado su vida a luchar
contra las violaciones de derechos
humanos del gobierno iraní una de sus
banderas es su batalla para eliminar el
uso obligatorio del hijab en la
república islámica en este episodio
conversaremos con ella sobre su trabajo
las amenazas que recibe constantemente y
su situación de seguridad para entrar en
contexto aquí está la historia
la policía ha estado frente a mi casa ya
por dos semanas cuando les pregunté por
qué estaban aquí me dijeron que era para
protegerme la periodista y activista por
los derechos humanos de los iraníes más
y alineyad confirmó ser objetivo de un
plan para callar su trabajo el 13 de
julio de 2021 fiscales estadounidenses
acusaron a cuatro presuntos agentes de
inteligencia de teherán de conspirar
para secuestrarla los hombres grabaron a
su familia la siguieron e investigaron
cómo sacarla de nueva york- en un barco
de alta velocidad que se dirigía a
caracas venezuela condenamos
categóricamente el peligroso y
despreciable complot de irán para
secuestrar a una ciudadana
estadounidense en suelo estadounidense
defenderemos enérgicamente a los
ciudadanos y los intereses
estadounidenses alineyad quien ha
contribuido al servicio de idioma persa
voice of america financiado por el
gobierno de eeuu es una defensora de las
mujeres crítica del gobierno de hassan
roja ni y contestataria de un doble
estándar en política internacional con
irán por ello es víctima de intimidación
y amenazas constantemente ella misma
denunció que en varias ocasiones agentes
iraníes intentaron persuadir la de
viajar
los países con amenazas a su familia en
la república islámica para obligarla a
presentarse a juicio en teherán su
hermano mayor está en prisión por
alertar la las autoridades
estadounidenses aseguran que en los
últimos años oficiales iraníes han
engañado a varios activistas extranjeros
para que viajen a destinos donde fueron
secuestrados y enviados de regreso a
irán el ex hasta antes de 1979 las
mujeres iraníes podían vestirse con un
estilo occidental se podían ver en las
calles de faldas cortas y camisetas pero
la revolución islámica trabajo una
interpretación estricta de la ley
islámica y con una nueva visión de la
modestia se dio una regresión en la que
las mujeres tuvieron que cubrirse el
cabello o dejar el maquillaje y también
tapar todo su cuerpo
las voces contra ese estilo de vida que
ya perdura hace más de 20 años se siguen
alzando hoy con más fuerza y una de
ellas es más y al inei al que se conecta
con nosotros desde eeuu más igual como
ella soy
hola gracias por jardín zen gracias por
su tiempo your fight y que su lucha
contra el uso obligatorio del hijab es
sólo una de las muchas causas que
representaría 16ta no es sólo una
discusión sobre un código de vestimenta
porque es la libertad de cubrir la
cabeza de una mujer una protesta contra
violaciones de derechos en su país
déjame empezar por ti imagina que cada
mañana alguien acude a ti desde que
tienes siete años y te dice que tienes
que cubrir tu hermoso cabello te dice
que si no cubres tu cabeza entonces no
podrás ir a la escuela no podrás recibir
una educación tú no podrás vivir en tu
amado país
homeland mobiliarias tu protestas porque
esto se trata de tu dignidad y millones
de ciudadanos iraníes no creen que esto
es solo por cubrir la cabeza con una
pequeña pieza de ropa es por una
dictadura religiosa que le dice a la
mitad de la población tú no eres lo
suficientemente madura nosotros vamos a
tomar las decisiones sobre tu cuerpo
y es por eso que las mujeres en irán
están furiosas mira voy a decirte algo
si tú y yo
ambas vamos a mi hermoso país irán tú
recibirás ataques yo recibirá ataques
sólo por sabes ser así elegir tu propio
código de vestimenta es fresco yo te
echarán del aeropuerto irás a la cárcel
es por eso que lance esta campaña
miércoles blancos para decir que estamos
en el siglo 21 y que la dictadura
debería dejarnos en paz
somos lo suficientemente maduras para
tomar las decisiones de nuestro cuerpo
body eso es es tan simple y yo no sé por
qué ellos quieren saber ellos arrestaron
a mi hermano arrestaron a las personas
que se unieron a la campaña ellos hacen
todo para hacerme callar rights o soy yo
a ustedes la creadora de miércoles
blancos por favor cuéntenos sobre esa
campaña y cómo funciona su plataforma mi
libertad maestrat y freedom works y
consta usted recibe constantemente
videos de mujeres protestando la hijab
incluso aunque puedan enfrentarse a la
cárcel
exactamente eso de hecho te muestra que
las mujeres en irán son tan valientes
que se arriesgan a tiempo en prisión al
protestar contra la república islámica y
su código de vestimenta con the face of
free porque ellas creen que la libertad
no es libre
quinché te voy a dar un ejemplo ahora
mismo mientras hablo contigo hay una
mujer llamada money the arab soy y ella
volvió a prisión ella recibió 16 años de
cárcel por unirse a la campaña de los
miércoles blancos y su hija ya se aman
arian y recibió también una pena de 16
años hoy cuando ella estaba volviendo a
prisión porque estaba libre con fianza
ella hizo un vídeo y yo lo publiqué en
mi instagram de escucharla
chigna ahora ella es tan valiente ella
ni siquiera está hablando de ella misma
ella está hablando de esas personas que
son asesinadas en irán por protestar
ahora mismo mientras hablo los iraníes
están protestando contra cortes de agua
en la provincia de juzestán y reciben
disparos en la cabeza reciben disparos
en el pecho y son asesinados
así que las personas en irán ellos sólo
tienen su cámara ellos pueden enviarme
vídeos yo tengo sabes en instagram
twitter facebook en todos combinados
tengo 7 millones de seguidores más que
el líder supremo ayatolá de irán y eso
de hecho te muestra que las mujeres
están usando su plataforma sus redes
sociales para protestar contra la
censura para protestar contra la
dictadura y mi trabajo es solo darles
voz a estas mujeres valientes a estas
personas valientes en la sociedad
grave y por william de sosa l
women trust en todo el mundo nosotras
las mujeres somos oprimidas al reclamar
nuestro derecho a gobernar nuestros
cuerpos y nuestros destinos en irán sin
embargo la opresión puede ser un ejemplo
extremo de las consecuencias que
sufrimos como mujeres hay casos
especialmente dolorosos del sexismo de
acceso a software y los traerás por
favor ilustre nos sobre cómo una mujer
puede ir a prisión o incluso ser víctima
de ataques con nacido en un país como
irán y todo por un velo
ya hay made man y si yo hago muchos
documentales sobre mujeres que si tú ve
su rostro sus caras están simbolizando
la dictadura ellos tiran nacidos en sus
rostros atrás y donde face en los jazz
han perdido la vista han perdido su
salud y por qué porque ellas quieren ser
como tú y como yo
guanajay esta es la forma en la que
quiero ser y tengo que decir que todas
las leyes de mi país van en contra de
las mujeres como mujer no te permiten
montar una bicicleta no te permiten
entrar a un estadio está prohibido
cantar sola
es creer eso singh solo hay un peligro
tu no puedes tener la custodia de tu
hijo ni siquiera te permiten viajar al
extranjero sin tener permiso de tu
esposo no puede ser una jueza no puede
ser presidenta
esto se llama régimen de apartheid de
género
pero lo que rompe mi corazón es que el
mundo entero está viendo este régimen y
ellos están tratando de hacer un trato y
negociar con este régimen sin considerar
que las mujeres están luchando en irán y
que están yendo a prisión una de las
mujeres que está en prisión ahora mismo
su nombre esa voz o churchill swan y
ella recibió una sentencia de 26 años
ella sólo tiene 20 años y yo no puedo
creerlo y tal vez tú puedes pensar que
yo estoy a salvo aquí en eeuu hablando
de esto no el régimen fue tras mi
hermano lo arrestó ellos llevaron a mi
hermana la televisión iraní para
deshonrar me públicamente y
recientemente ellos estaban intentando
secuestrar me aquí en suelo
estadounidense este es el tipo de
régimen del que te estoy hablando
ellos aterrorizan a sus propias mujeres
y lo hacen todo para mantenernos
calladas pero tú conoces el poder de las
mujeres no nos vamos a rendir hasta que
nos deshagamos de este régimen de
apartheid de género hay uno un show de
yuso fijaba had become el uso del hijab
se ha convertido en un estereotipo
abierto a muchas interpretaciones
incluyendo la duplicidad como un símbolo
de opresión pero también posicionado
como un signo de respeto por las
creencias islámicas usted ha sido
acusada de islamofobia por defender su
derecho a no usar el velo hay un doble
estándar cual es el feminismo real
eso es horrible cuando la gente me acusa
a mí diciéndome que yo estoy causando
islamofobia por hablar en contra del
hijab obligatorio o de las leyes de la
sharía por favor estoy pidiendo a todas
esas mujeres que nos etiquetan que vayan
y vivan bajo las leyes de la sharía
vayan y reciban los golpes yo soy una
mujer de irán y yo tengo el derecho de
decir que sí
yo estoy asustada de todas las leyes de
la sharía
si yo solo quisiera sentir el viento en
mi pelo si quiero dejar que mi pelo
caiga si obtengo castigos y luego tú me
dices que me quede callada porque causó
islamofobia o causas de homofobia se
trata de mi pelo esto se trata de mi
cuerpo mi elección
porque cuando se trata de un país de
occidente mi cuerpo mi elección es
importante pero cuando se trata del
medio oriente y la república islámica tú
dices que vas a causar islamofobia que
no se sepa si para mí eso es hipocresía
y rompe mi corazón cuando veo algunas de
las feministas mantenerse en silencio
cuando ellas ven que sus hermanas están
siendo atacadas solo por dejar su pelo
suelto solo porque sabes se están
expresando la república islámica que nos
golpea que cuelga a las personas y
protestan la república islámica merece
un llamado de atención tú debes en
realidad condenar a la república
islámica no mantenernos a nosotras en
silencio si eres una verdadera feminista
debe apoyarnos debes mostrar tu
solidaridad dos horas
yo lo perdí todo en mi vida mi tierra mi
seguridad yo tengo que mirar sobre mi
hombro a ver cuándo va a venir el
régimen aquí a matarme
esta es la república islámica esta es la
verdadera cara del régimen y ahora tú me
estás diciendo que yo soy la que causó
islamofobia
la homofobia y tú tienes que deshacerte
de este extremismo de este régimen
islámico y si te mantienes en silencio
entonces tú vas a ser la próxima víctima
de la república islámica
este es mi punto y estoy segura de que
tú me entiendes más ya línea de winston
with you think you thank you for your
work a nuestros televidentes gracias por
estar con nosotros en ellas hoy y nos
vemos próximamente continúen en france24
[Música]